لنلقي نظره اكثر قربا على الموقفين الصيني
والهندي من الحرب هذان الموقفان اللذان
تعتبرهما روسيا مهيمنين جدا على الساحه
العالميه مثلث العلاقه بين هذه الدول
تختلف قوته من ضلع لاخر فما موقف الدولتين
حيل روسيا بشكل عام في الازمه التي شارفت
على انهاء عامها الاول
نشرت تقريرا عن الموقف الصيني وقالت ان اي
انتكاسه لروسيا في اوكرانيا ستضعفها
سياسيا وعسكريا وبالتالي
ستضعف موقف الصين في مواجهه واشنطن
وحلفائها القلق الصينيه اتى بحسب الصحيفه
من ان زياده الدعم العسكري الغربي
لاوكرانيا سيؤثر على الموقف الروسي
ميدانيا ما يجعل بكين اكثر ميلا للضغط
باتجاه وقف اطلاق النار لمنع المزيد من
وبالطبع الحيلوله دون هزيمه روسيا لا ننسى
ان للصين مكاسب اقتصاديه مع روسيا تسعى
للحفاظ عليها فهي تتطلع لزياده وارداتها
من النفط والغاز والسلع الزراعيه الروسيه
اضافه لاقامه المزيد من شركات الطاقه
المشتركه في القطب الشمالي وزياده
الاستثمار في السكك الحديد والموانئ
الروسيه لكن ليس من الواضح حتى الان كيف
ستنعكس كل هذه الامور على سياسه ضبط النفس
التي تتبعها بكين نتحدث هنا عن امتناعها
حتى اللحظه عن دعم موسكو عسكريا نتذكر
تحذير وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه من ان
الصين تدرس دعم روسيا باسلحه مميته
كنا نراقب هذا عن كثب وحتى الان راينا
شركات صينيه وهناك لا فرق بين الشركات
الخاصه والدوله رايناهم يقدمون دعما
باسلحه غير مميته لروسيا لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا القلق الان يعتمد على المعلومات
التي لدينا عن انهم يفكرون في تقديم اسلحه
قاتله
لكن الشكوك في سلوك الصين لا ياتي فقط من
واشنطن فوزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولو قالت ان بلادها تراقب انشطه شركات
صينيه يحتمل ان تقدم مساعده لروسيا في
حربها في اوكرانيا كولونا اكدت ان فرنسا
تتحدث بكل دبلوماسيه ووضوح مع تكين وتامل
ان لا تمد يد العون لروسيا وان يكون لها
موقف واضح في جلسه مجلس الامن الدولي قبيل
ذكرى انطلاقه الحرب الرد الصيني جاء من
وزاره الخارجيه التي قالت ان الولايات
المتحده وليس الصين هي من توفر تدفقا لا
نهايه له للاسلحه
الولايات المتحده هي اكبر مورد للاسلحه
الى ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا امس اعلنت
الولايات المتحده عن 500 مليون دولار
كمساعدات عسكريه ذلك يجعل البعض يتساءل
عما تنوي الولايات المتحده فعله من خلال
الادعاء الكاذب بان الصين تقدم اسلحه تدعي
الولايات المتحده انها تحافظ على السلام
لكنها في الواقع تكسب المال من الازمه